food and security another unfortunate
impact of covet 19.
the demand here in southern nevada has
roughly doubled since the start of the
pandemic
and this morning we're finding out a bit
more about how local organizations are
keeping up with that demand
hector mejia live outside three square
foot bank in the northeast valley with
those details hi hector
hey there alex good morning this massive
warehouse right behind me is a new
campus that opened recently back in
september here by craig and lamb and it
opened after years in the making take a
look
three square says it could not have come
at a better time
it allowed them to increase food storage
capacity and expand
services this facility alone for example
serves more than 10 thousand seniors
every single month
according to three squares chief
operating officer larry scott
food insecurity was already high to
start with we've seen emergency food
distribution sites pop
up all across the valley at school
campuses casino parking lots other
places
and at the start of the pandemic
southern nevada had about a 12 percent
food insecurity rate
that roughly that's roughly 270 000
people who
did not know where their next meal would
be coming from
and now that number is pushing closer to
450
000 people even as things open back
up those who fall into food security
usually stay there for an extended
period of time it takes longer for them
to get out of that
as we've mentioned before the
hospitality industry obviously taking a
huge hit
three square says their hospitality
partners though are still continuing to
donate funds and
donate food also offering parking lots
for their food distribution efforts and
even through all of the hardships three
square
says there is a lesson to take away from
this we'll have that part of the story
still ahead of the next half hour and
also
how this new facility is increasing the
amount of phone calls they can take as
they help people here
across the valley reporting from a very
windy and chilly northeast valley hector
mejia
8 news now